et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
le rendre bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nos députés de la Corse du Sud
président du groupe horizon à
l'Assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour Christelle Bertrand bonjour
Yannick la dépêche on va évidemment
parler de la réforme des retraites
Elisabeth borne qui rencontre donc les
partenaires sociaux aujourd'hui à
Matignon c'est la première fois depuis
la présentation de la réforme est-ce
qu'elle doit faire un pas vers les
syndicats et mettre cette réforme sur
pause d'abord le pas c'était de lancer
l'invitation si je peux me permettre de
recevoir d'écouter
pas forcément être d'accord parce que il
s'avère qu'il y a encore des points de
blocage notamment sur la réforme des
retraites et je pense ouvrir les
perspectives d'autres choses parce que
je continue de penser que la réforme des
retraites est importante dans notre pays
on voit bien ce qu'elle mobilise mais il
y a aussi d'autres sujets et je crois
que ces sujets doivent être traités avec
les partenaires sociaux cette rencontre
n'intervient pas un peu tard
c'était elle possible à vendre vous
aviez
il y a eu je vous rappelle
l'important de rappeler la chronologie
vous avez eu depuis plusieurs mois des
rencontres je rappelle quand même que au
départ la réforme devait être annoncée
avant les vacances de Noël que c'est à
la demande de la première ministre que
le délai de négociation a été rallongé
les syndicats ont dit non nous ne
voulons pas la retraite 64 ans nous
voulons maintenir le statu quo et
ensuite le Parlement a commencé à
travailler sur la question à la demande
du gouvernement et on voit bien
aujourd'hui que si on focalise
uniquement sur les retraites il y a un
désaccord mais un désaccord démocratique
ça veut dire que rien ne va bouger
aujourd'hui
sur les retraites et vous dites il faut
pas focalise sur les retraites je pense
effectivement ça sera difficile puisque
aujourd'hui vous avez le texte qui entre
les mains du Conseil constitutionnel et
le 14 avril nous saurons ce qu'il en a
déjà par rapport à ce contrôle
constitutionnel et je crois je crois que
il sera bon pour pays pour les
partenaires sociaux pour le gouvernement
pour tout le monde un moment de passer à
autre chose
d'envisager aussi d'autres réformes la
répartition des richesses des
oppositions et les syndicats qui disent
on peut pas passer à autre chose tant
qu'il y a cette réforme oui j'entends
j'entends je l'entends
vous dites la première mise fait un pas
vers les syndicats en les demandant de
venir les syndicats doivent également je
le pense à un moment avoir peut-être une
autre manière de construire les choses
mais en tout cas moi ce que je veux dire
c'est que avant de se parler avant de
dire si ça marchait pas marché les sons
cette journée se passait et on fera les
commentaires une fois les rencontres
terminées sur quoi est-ce qu'elle
pourrait encore bouger sur la réforme
des retraites on a compris que la mesure
d'âge n'était pas discutable est-ce
qu'il y a encore des choses à modifier
sur cette réforme je vais répéter ce que
j'ai dit pendant des mois et des
semaines vous vous rendez vous compte
que dans cette réforme il y a 7
milliards d'euros qui ont été mis sur la
table pour corriger des des inégalités
des petites injustices voire même de
grandes injust dans le système existant
c'est à dire celui de la retraite à 62
ans personne n'en a parlé on a focalisé
sur la mesure d'âge j'avais même entendu
monsieur Martinez dire il y a des
mesures très bien comme par exemple le
fait de compter les années sur les
contrats aidés des années 80 l'étude
dans les carrières de ceux qui les
avaient accomplis c'est d'ailleurs une
proposition d'horizon
a voulu voir autre chose que le l'âge de
départ et aujourd'hui on est enfermé
là-dedans et je veux dire que tout le
monde dit le gouvernement s'est enfermé
dans cette logique de l'âge de départ
mais il n'y a pas que le gouvernement
qui s'enfermait là-dedans aujourd'hui
puisque on voit bien que on ne parle que
de cela un moment je crois qu'il est
simple pour le débat démocratique de
passer à autre chose surtout si la loi
devient légalement applicable qu'est-ce
que vous avez raté vous avez critiqué
dans la méthode du gouvernement sur ces
négociations et la manière de
communiquer sur la réforme des retraites
qu'est-ce qu'il aurait fallu faire selon
moi j'ai pas critiqué j'ai parlé
d'introspection il faut toujours se
remettre en question dans la vie je suis
à la base et Luc local j'ai été maire
pendant huit années président
d'agglomération ça il faut se remettre
en question et forcément quand vous avez
des blocages comme ceci il faut il faut
réfléchir à la méthode c'est ce que nous
sommes en train de faire par ailleurs en
quoi la méthode était-elle mauvaise elle
était pas mauvaise mais d'abord je
voudrais dire quand même au crédit de la
première ministre et du gouvernement je
ne connais pas de gouvernement qui s'en
est sorti sans balafre lorsqu'il a mis
le sujet des retraites sur sur la table
c'est impossible dans notre pays c'est
comme aux États-Unis lorsque vous parlez
des armes à feu voilà il y a des sujets
qui dans dans les pays sont clivants et
on n'arrive pas à les mettre sur la
table et à travailler sereinement sur la
question il y a aucune réforme des
retraites qui s'est passé dans de bonnes
conditions dans ce pays donc ça c'est
une première chose ensuite effectivement
nous sommes dans une situation politique
qui nécessite à mon avis un changement
de méthode un changement de braquet
pourquoi il y a pas de majorité absolue
à l'Assemblée nationale on sent que les
Français
les Français sont comme beaucoup
d'autres peuples dans le monde
aujourd'hui en questionnement par
rapport à leur démocratie
représentatives il y a peut-être une
nouvelle manière de faire les choses qui
est atteinte quelle méthode vous
attendez vous allez rencontrer Elizabeth
bandes ce soir quelle méthode vous
attendez peut-être des textes plus
courts
précis
un travail de négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux mais également avec
les forces politiques qu'on pose le pays
en amont beaucoup plus en amont des
débats un peu plus sereins et apaisés
donc ça ça
49-3 clairement ça a cassé quelque chose
entre la majorité parlementaire et
l'exécutif vous interrogez sur la
manière dont les Français ressentent
l'utilisation de cet outil qui est un
outil constitutionnel donc prévu qui a
déjà été utilisé à de nombreuses
reprises qui auraient pu être supprimées
par d'autres majorités avant compris par
ceux qui sont dans l'opposition
aujourd'hui qui
n'aurait pas fallu l'utiliser moi en
tout cas ce que je dis c'est que je ne
sais pas ce qui se serait passé si ce
texte n'avait pas été adopté par une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale s'il
avait été rejeté est-ce que il était
possible d'arriver avec un échec sur ce
sujet
plaisir que cette réforme a été mise sur
la table c'est pas nécessite mais la
nouvelle méthode est-ce que ça veut dire
aussi plus s'écouter les parlementaires
de la majorité
suffisamment depuis le début de ce
quinquennat j'ai un dialogue constant et
productif avec la première ministre j'ai
pas eu le sentiment depuis le début de
ce quinquennat d'avoir une première
ministre qui n'écoute pas lorsque je
m'adressais mais quand le président de
la République là pour le coup c'est lui
qui dit il va peut-être falloir passer
moins par le Parlement parce que tout ça
est trop lourd prend trop de temps
est-ce que c'est la bonne méthode moi je
fais partie de ceux qui considèrent que
nous légiférons beaucoup en France
peut-être trop c'est une réalité je suis
donc la voie
règlementaires est à disposition là
encore une fois on n'a pas révolutionné
quoi que ce soit c'est une possibilité
ensuite vous pouvez avoir des textes moi
nombreux moins bavards je vous rappelle
quand même qu'elle législation en France
dont on s'accorde à dire qu'elle est
parfois un peu trop bavarde mais c'est
un peu en contradiction que ce que vous
venez de dire les français demandent à
être plus écoutés mais peut-être on peut
utiliser la voie réglementaire c'est
mais on peut utiliser la voix
réglementaire en écoutant les Français
c'est pas forcément antinomique vous
pouvez très bien prendre des mesures
dans les ministères ça passe par quoi
par des grands débats par comment on
écoute plus les Français regardez je
vois quand même nous sommes dans une
période de paradoxe que le Parlement est
bloqué et hier encore on a voté une loi
anti squats on a voté une loi sur le
nucléaire à 400 voix contre 100
d'opposition on a voté à cet homme de
texte à l'unanimité lors de la Semaine
de l'Assemblée à la semaine dernière il
y a un débat sur la fin de vie qui
visiblement et a cité en exemple moi
ceux qui ont participé président des a
reçu hier et en fait on focalise encore
une fois sur ce qui ne fonctionne pas je
comprends on parle souvent des trains
qui n'arrivent pas à l'heure c'est comme
ça mais tout n'est pas complètement
désespérant dans le pays je vois aussi
ça veut dire que pour eux il est
possible de pour vous pardon il est
possible de trouver des majorités textes
par textes la démonstration en effet
elle a encore été hier et je pense
qu'elle le sera elle le sera à l'avenir
vous le voyez bien et des larges
majorité vous venez des républicains
horizon est-ce que vous pensez que
certains d'entre eux s'appeleront de
rentrer au gouvernement est-ce qu'il
faut que certains d'entre eux
gouvernement pour vous rentrez pour
rentrer je crois que le débauchage a
montré ses limites et je pense pas que
ce soit aujourd'hui attendu par qui que
ce soit en revanche s'entendre sur une
projection moi je le plaide depuis le
début nous plaisions avec Édouard
Philippe pour une coalition c'est pas
dans la culture française c'est pas dans
la culture politique de notre pays de se
mettre autour de la table et dire voilà
nous ne sommes pas de la même famille
mais nous contractualisons un programme
de gouvernement pour 5 années ça n'a pas
été fait est-ce que ça peut être fait
encore je ne sais pas en juger par les
déclarations des uns des autres ça va
être difficile
et débauchage individuels je pense pas
qu'il soit forcément attendu en revanche
s'unir demain pour défendre à cet homme
de valeur de principes d'idées et former
un gouvernement d'union républicaine si
d'aventure on trouve preneur moi je suis
plutôt pour vous y travaillez avec
Édouard Philippe vous discutez en ce
moment avec certains membres de la
discussion elle est permanente d'abord
parce que géographiquement nous sommes
proches les uns des autres dans
l'hémicycle et ensuite comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure mon parcours
politique personnel est celui d'un
nombre important des députés horizons
fait que nous les connaissions et que
nous savons un petit peu ce qui les
anime il y en a qui sont ouverts ils le
démontre aussi par leur vote depuis le
début du quinquennat il y en a qui le
sont moins c'est aussi une question de
sociologie électorale de leur
circonscription et on voit bien que vous
dites pas une question d'ambition
personnelle ah des ambitions
personnelles vous savez ça existe ça
existera et ça a toujours existé ceux
qui sont ouverts est-ce qu'il faut pas
que les arrimés plus fortement
aujourd'hui à la majorité et peut-être
par est-ce que ça passe par un
changement de Premier ministre
je ne le pense pas à titre personnel ce
comment faire en sorte que les voix ne
vous manquent pas comme ça a été le cas
sur la réforme des retraites ou qui est
en doute en tous les cas sur ceux qui
voteront ou pas un texte proposer des
projets qui a recueillent la sentiment
je vous l'ai dit c'est possible encore
de on l'a vu même sur des textes
difficiles sur la le paquet pouvoir
d'achat du mois de juillet a gagné
d'avance on sortait des élections il y
avait quand même une tension palpable
dans l'hémicycle nous avons obtenu le
large majorité pour venir en aide aux
Français dans ce contexte d'inflation
forte donc Premier ministre de droite ça
n'aiderait pas justement à retisser les
liens et aller consolider écoutez c'est
un choix qui appartient au président de
la République et moi en ce qui me
concerne je vous le dis encore je crois
que la première ministre dans le
contexte difficile que nous connaissons
elle est plutôt bien à sa place elle
reçoit en ce moment les parlementaires
notamment les parlementaires de
l'opposition les parlementaires de la
nuque ont refusé de se rendre à Matignon
Olivier forêt marine tondulé ils sont
allés en tant que chef de partie mais il
y a quand même des divisions vous
comprenez que les parlementaires de
gauche n'est pas souhaité s'y rendre moi
quand je suis invité j'ai pour habitude
de me rendre au rendez-vous pour une
bonne simple raison c'est que le
dialogue démocratique il n'est pas que
dans les assemblées il est aussi par il
se fait aussi par ses rencontres vous
voyez bien les syndicats ont accepté de
se rendre à l'invitation de la première
ministre
je trouve un peu désobligeants et des
gens mais non moins surprenant parce que
je ne pensais pas que les filles se
rendent à cette rencontre mais que ne se
rendent pas je ne pense pas que ce soit
très bien pour le dialogue républicains
spécialistes et les écologistes attitude
non non mais vous avez vu il y a une
représentation socialiste et écologiste
qui s'est rendu à Matignon donc il y a
pas forcément la même ligne et puis si
je commençais à rentrer dans l'exégèse
des déclarations contradictoires dans
les parties de la nuse je pense qu'on y
prendrait plus que 20 minutes Emmanuel
Macron doit recevoir les présidents de
groupe parlementaire pour vous
il le fera s'il le souhaite
on est dans un système où le président
de la République n'est pas à la même
place que la chef du gouvernement la
chef du gouvernement et la chef de la
majorité elle doit rencontrer les
parlementaires et ton contact permanent
avec eux et si président de la
République estime nécessaire il le fera
aujourd'hui dans la majorité on dit que
il est reproche d'être très isolé à
l'Élysée ne pas voir suffisamment et les
Français et les parlementaires est-ce
que ça a pu influer sur la manière dont
il a géré la crise autant de la réforme
des retraites d'abord je renvoie au
passé je ne me souviens pas d'avoir
entendu parler d'un président de la
République qui n'était pas isolé depuis
que je m'intéresse à la vie politique
c'est la fonction cette fonction elle
est elle est faite ainsi ensuite nous
vivons des moments particuliers dans nos
démocraties libérales je le dis en
France mais également ailleurs où on
remet en question notre système
démocratique et je vais vous faire une
confidence je pense que le prochain ou
la prochaine présidente de la République
à un moment vous interrogerez un
parlementaire sur son isolement parce
parce que c’est cette fonction qui veut
cela là il a fait quand même très peu de
déplacements en Provence depuis sa
réélection on le voit beaucoup moins
présent
auprès des Français en tous les cas oui
mais on l'a vu à l'occasion de d'un
déplacement dernièrement donc je pense
que le Président de la République qui
doit aussi représenter la France à
l'étranger ce qu'il fait d'ailleurs il
est en Chine vous verrez bien que que
ces contacts permanents que le président
doit avoir se feront après c'est une
question de calendrier et puis
franchement aujourd'hui avec la
situation de tension dans laquelle se
trouve le pays est-ce que c'est utile
que le Président de la République se
rende tous les jours en province je ne
le pense pas non plus donc c'est une
question de gestion du rapport avec les
Français et de gestion du temps
politique dans lequel nous sommes alors
puisque vous parlez de tension justement
demain nouvelle journée de mobilisation
est-ce que vous craignez des
manifestations à nouveau massives et
débordements je n'ai jamais créé les
manifestations massives je les respecte
et je constate que lorsqu'elles sont
organisées par les syndicats elle se
passe dans des conditions tout à fait
respectables ce que je crains toujours
c'est les violences et l'usage que
certains en font pour notamment mettre
en cause les forces de l'ordre ce qui
est inacceptable et pour celles et ceux
qui seraient tenter d'aller manifester
pour casser des biens publics privés
pour s'affronter avec les policiers
j'espère que la réponse sera à la
hauteur de ce que nous devons donner
c'est-à-dire le respect de la démocratie
et donc de la légalité républicaine à ce
propos est-ce que vous en êtes du projet
de commission d'enquête sur les
violences qui ont eu lieu à Sainte
Soline nous présenter hier à une
résolution qui sera votée après la
suspension des vacances de Pâques
c'est-à-dire début mais par l'Assemblée
nationale pour pouvoir lancer cette
commission d'enquête qui à mon avis est
nécessaire parce que faut pas faire
passer les vessies pour les lanternes
aujourd'hui non mais aujourd'hui
j'entends j'entends certains qui
essayent de dévier le débat sur ce qu'on
appelle les violences policières non non
les violences c'est participer à des
manifestations illégales parce que non
autorisées les violences c'est aller AR
entraîner pour tuer pour blesser les
forces de l'ordre pour détruire des
biens privés ou public les gains c'est
ça si j'ai bien compris la commission
d'enquête elle a vocation a enquêter sur
les violences qui ont été exercées
contre les forces de l'ordre et pas dans
l'autre sens c'est bien ça vous avez pas
souhaité comment sont organisés
aujourd'hui ces groupes
radicalisés qui mettent en péril je le
pense la démocratie dans notre pays
parce qu'ils veulent le coup de force
permanent et moi ce que je demande
aujourd'hui c'est que chaque responsable
politique se positionne clairement par
rapport à ces violences et d'ici les
condamne ou pas
de solides
que ceux qui exercent le métier du
maintien de l'ordre dans ce pays que ce
soit les gendarmes ou les policiers les
statistiques sont là pour le démontrer
les sanctions elles sont là quand elles
doivent être là en revanche que ce soit
systémique et systématique je m'inscris
en faux ça n'existe pas un problème de
stratégie de maintien de l'ordre
on peut toujours mieux faire mais moi ce
que je remarque c'est que dans un pays
où il y a beaucoup de manifestations il
y a pas des morts tous les jours c'est
pas le cas dans toutes les démocraties
je vous le dis encore une fois et que le
maintien de l'ordre est assuré dans ce
pays de manière à faire en sorte que on
respecte le droit de manifester
sans pour autant respecter ce que
certains font c'est à dire casser tenter
de tuer tenter de blesser mais ce n'est
pas du rôle des parlementaires de
vérifier que tout s'est bien passé du
côté des forces de l'ordre elles sont de
Soline aussi aujourd'hui encore un
manifester qui est toujours dans le
commun c'est le principe le principe
d'une commission d'enquête parlementaire
c'est le contradictoire il y aura des
auditions et des questions seront posées
et vous savez que c'est une commission
d'enquête dans lesquelles figurait
également des membres de l'opposition
ils pourront également poser les
questions qui estimeront nécessaires à
ceux qui seront auditionnés
évident que le ministre de l'Intérieur
se soit auditionné dans cette commission
le procureur qui enquête justement sur
les événements de l'usage de la force
n'est naturellement pas dans une
démocratie absolue mais encadrée et
conditionnée par la loi c'est quelque
chose que vous partagez et que vous
allez vérifier c'est le principe de
l'État de droit c'est la violence
légitime de l'état
en réponse à une violence qui aime pas
oui
donc vous allez vous réunir aujourd'hui
le groupe horizon à l'Assemblée pour
envisager la suite est-ce que vous savez
déjà sur quelle piste vous allez quelle
piste vous allez proposer aux résidents
de la République pour tourner la page de
cette réforme des retraites j'aurais
l'occasion de rencontrer la première
ministre en fin de journée aussi pour
justement lui dire ce que nous avons
évoqué avec mes collègues on nous a
demandé de réfléchir depuis quelques
semaines au rythme de travail et des
parlementaires je vous parlais également
de la méthode à savoir celle de la
concertation préalable
à tout texte législatif avec la majorité
en priorité mais également avec les
oppositions la taille des textes comme
je vous le disais
et les sujets parce qu'il y a aussi des
sujets de cette moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on évoque la
répartition de l'effort dans le pays
parce que la sentiment d'injustice par
rapport à cela on sent chez les Français
qui d'ailleurs explique peut-être les
mobilisations davantage que la réforme
des retraites elle-même
et fort l'effort parce que on des
efforts aux Français en travaillant deux
ans de plus donc je crois qu'ensuite
l'effort il doit être réparti de manière
peut-être plus équilibrée
vous avez une loi travail avec un accord
avec les syndicats qui lui à part la CGT
et bien là avec Lagny vous le savez qui
a prévoit un certain nombre de choses on
peut peut-être aller plus loin mais vous
avez d'autres sujets je le crois encore
une fois qui veut dire qu'il fallait
vite sur le partage de la valeur il faut
vite le transformer en loi faut pas le
brusquer il faut remettre je crois ce
sujet sur la table et en revanche on
peut l'améliorer l'accord a été trouvé
il est une base je crois de bonnes
factures plutôt solide mais on peut
aussi avec un travail parlementaire de
qualité améliorer cela et élargir le
champ et j'aime par exemple vous
rediscutez de la taxation des super
dividendes c'est quelque chose qui peut
être envisagé ça fait partie des sujets
qui doivent être sur la table encore une
fois si je crois que les connaissances
n'en voulait pas jusqu'à présent oui
mais encore une fois vous le savez bien
nous avons une situation qui à mon avis
nous oblige aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des
Français
si demain on ne met pas sur la table
tout ces sujets qui aujourd'hui sont
dans le débat public je crois qu'on fait
une erreur ensuite vous avez d'autres
sujets voilà pourra pas continuer à s'en
parler de notre système éducatif l'école
c'est un grand sujet l'accès aux soins
le logement
autorité de l'État je vous en parlais
tout à l'heure je crois qu'il y a un
vrai sujet ça fait partie du des sujets
abordés par le Conseil national de la
refondation ça suffit pas ça veut dire
qu'il faut les aborder différemment mon
collègue Frédéric valtoux
proposera une loi qui sera examinée
probablement au mois de juin dans la
lignée de ce que nous disions dans le
groupe horizon depuis plusieurs mois
déjà à savoir la nécessité de travailler
autrement sur l'accès aux soins
notamment avec les ordres des médecins
définir peut-être une régulation une
autre manière de de mailler le
territoire parce que vous avez entendu
les médecins à s'installer dans des
zones dans des déserts médicaux c'est un
peu la position d'horizon ce sera pas
une contrainte aussi forte que cela mais
nous aurons dans le cadre de cette loi
un certain nombre de choses à faire
valoir dans la lignée de ce que nous
vivons
il faut une obligation non pas à temps
complet mais à un moment donné du temps
sur un territoire limitrophe qui a
besoin de soins je crois que c'est pas
forcément s'il y a juste que ça vous
l'avez proposé déjà il y a une PPL là
dessus qui n'a pas abouti vous espérez
que les choses un peu évolué depuis je
vous dis que nous avons une loi qui va
être discutée dans le cadre d'un accord
avec le gouvernement parce que nous
avons travaillé
j'espère bien puisque ça a été préparé
avec le gouvernement
sur la fin de vie Emmanuel Macron a
promis une loi avant la fin de l'été la
convention citoyenne demande une
évolution de la loi classé monétique
avec la mise en place d'une année active
à mourir vous êtes favorable
moi j'attends de voir quand le sujet
sera sur la table de l'Assemblée
nationale
pour principe d'être assez humble sur
ces sujets et je peux vous dire d'ores
et déjà qu'il y aura pas de consignes de
vote dans mon groupe parce que ce sont
des sujets qui ont un trait à la
conscience de tout à chacun donc je ne
sais pas ce que je ferais sera en
fonction de ce qui sera face à moi et je
peux vous dire c'est que je ne donnerai
aucune consigne de vote sur ce sujet
un mot sur pour finir sur ce qui se
passe encore il y a une recrudescence
des attentats notamment contre des
mairies dans la région ajacienne que
vous connaissez bien est-ce que le
climat sur l'île menace les discussions
avec l'État sur la question de
l'autonomie je sais pas si c'est une
bonne chose de prendre le sujet comme ça
parce que les élus qui discutent avec le
Premier ministre la première ministre le
ministre de l'Intérieur le président de
la République
on dénoncé ces actes donc il y a pas de
soutien aujourd'hui de Monsieur siméone
et de sa majorité à de tels actes
d'abord je vais les condamner à mon tour
je l'ai déjà fait et apporter tout mon
soutien au maire et à la population des
deux communes qui a été touchée par ses
actes odieux et je veux dire que la
Corse elle a plus que jamais besoin
d'apaisement de paix et que c'est pas en
détruisant c'est pas un sac à Jean c'est
pas en donnant l'image de cette course
là qu'on va avancer donc ça c'est la
première chose ensuite on a besoin de
projet on a besoin de projet structurant
on a besoin de vision mais la paix c'est
très important mais que vous dit Gérald
Darmanin est-ce qu'il est prêt à
continuer les discussions avec le climat
actuel il est nécessaire le dialogue il
est indispensable faut pas le laisser
les liens ces filochés comme ça on voit
bien aujourd'hui l'état dans lequel se
retrouve les territoires d'outre-mer il
y a il y a des écarts qui ont été
élargis au fur et à mesure parce que le
dialogue a manqué donc le dialogue il
est indispensable je l'appelle de mes
vœux il faut le poursuivre mais il faut
aussi que en Corse on soit tous des
artisans de paix et des militants de la
paix qu'on se rendent prochainement
j'espère qu'il s'y rendra il y avait
une rencontre qui était prévue c'est
déjà rendu à le multiple reprise sur le
territoire insulaire et en tout cas je
crois que ce dialogue il doit il doit
persister et la paix doit être au cœur
de tout merci Laurent merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité la Une de La
Dépêche sont les médicaments encore
c'est à la Une de votre journal
Christelle merci beaucoup Laurent face
au club des territoires